à l'occasion de la soixante quinzième
journée internationale dédiée à la
mémoire des victimes de l'holocauste le
musée juif et centre de tolérance de
moscou présente sa toute nouvelle
exposition intitulée pas le temps pour
l'amour histoire de survivants de
l'holocauste lors de l'inauguration de
cette exposition le grand rabbin de
russie mais aussi les ambassadeurs en
russie de l'allemagne des etats-unis et
d'israël ont tour à tour pris la parole
pour rendre hommage aux victimes bien
entendu mais aussi pour souligner qu'il
était nécessaire de continuer à
combattre l'antisémitisme encore
aujourd'hui l'exposition en elle-même
est composé d'extraits de journaux
intimes de mémoire ou de biographies
publiées ces vingt dernières années par
d'anciens prisonniers des camps de
concentration des combattants juifs de
la résistance ou encore par leurs
enfants ou petits-enfants l'événement
présente aussi des oeuvres de l'artiste
français christian boltanski du
sculpteur polonais miroslaw balka ou
encore des installations d'artistes
contemporains israéliens à travers ses
oeuvres d'art est le récit de ses onze
histoires d'amour des histoires d'amour
qui ont su exister malgré les immenses
difficultés cette exposition propose
ainsi de nouvelles perspectives pour
parler du traumatisme est du devoir de
mémoire
[Musique]